peut être le choix petit fils de déporté
a motivé mon premier voyage à auschwitz
après c'est mon cerveau de médecins qui
a pris le dessus sur le petit fils de
déporté pour se poser les questions
auxquelles j'essaye de répondre dans les
programmes
eu plein de types d'expériences les plus
spectaculaires et les poètes les plus
horribles ont été celles de carl
clauberg à auschwitz qui était un gynéco
de renault qui voulaient stériliser les
femmes juives pour éviter bien sûr
qu'elles ne se reproduisent et en même
temps il fallait pas les tuer parce que
elle servait de main d'oeuvre
donc il a tenté de leur injecter du
format là qui était un mélange de formes
formuler d'autres choses dans les voies
génitales pour stériliser ses femmes
tout en ne le faisant pas mourir et les
témoignages de ces femmes montre
l'atrocité des douleurs qu'elle pouvait
ressentir y en a d'autres qui mettait
qui voulait savoir combien de temps on
mettait à mourir quand on était dans le
froid et donc ils ont pris des déportés
les ans minuh sur des brancards attaché
au milieu du camp d'auschwitz en plein
hiver où la température avoisine nés
entre -10 et -30 degrés il ya eu tous
ces expériences il ya mike kelley qui
injectait du bleu dans les yeux des
enfants qui a causé la mort de
deux jumeaux en même temps pour voir ce
qui se passait dans les organismes
quand il mourrait
des expériences y en a eu des dizaines
et dizaines ce sont des dizaines peut
être des centaines de médecins qui à
travers l'allemagne et les quand on fait
ce genre d'expériences médicales sur des
milliers de personnes tout était
volontaire personne ne leur imposer quoi
que ce soit il était convaincu que ces
expériences allez pouvoir faire avancer
l'humanité surtout une humanité
allemande et allez peut-être permettre
de sauver l'armée allemand
l'epa notion de l'humanité d'humanité
parce que les allemands considéré les
juifs par exemple puisque les tidianes
ont souffert aussi
mais les juifs comme n'étant pas des
êtres humains ni des animaux c'était à
part donc le mot humanité ne s'adaptent
pas du tout à ce que représente le
peuple juste puisque c'étaient pas des
humains
je pense qu'il est fondamental de parler
de ça parce que la pédagogie passe par
ça passe par eux
des choses à apprendre parce par la
répétition des choses pour que dans la
période qu'on traverse qui est quand
même un peu compliqué sur le plan de la
tolérance sur le plan de du des
communautarismes
voilà je crois qu'on est à un moment de
la vie de notre société où il n'est pas
mauvais de rappeler ce qui s'est passé
non pas pour considérer que le peuple
juif ou tzigane sont un peuple martyr
mais pour rappeler jusqu'où peut aller
la la bête humaine